what's the most painful lesson you've
learned that the heaviest things in life
aren't iron or gold but unmade decisions
when I got into a head-on collision when
I was 26 from a DUI I had a performance
coach at the time that was like these
unmade decisions that you're choosing
not to confront are literally going to
kill you he's like and you just got
lucky because you got a second shot that
was a painful lesson in that like it was
a massive wake-up call that I had all
this fear around decisions which was
really just hard conversations that I
was postponing that I needed to have and
I think when I was confronted with my
own death I was able to like nut up and
actually have this conversation because
I was like oh if I don't do this I will
stress myself out enough that I don't
want to be here